Giám đốc chủ tâm chống khu vô của Giám Mỹ Joe Ken, người Mỹ bày tháng 3 thông báo tự chất.
Trời biết không thể ủng hộ của chiến với Ivan Vili Sau Lương Tâm.
Trong thư gửi tổng thống đô nân trăm ông Ken Châu Sang,
chiến dịch quân sự hiện nay không xuất phát từ mối đe xóa trực tiếp đồ với Mỹ,
đồng thời bài tỏ lo ngại về những hệ lội lâu dài.
Đồng khai này, giết xa trực bối cảnh trình dựa giống Mỹ yên xói ra vỷ và tức tục lâu khác.
Gây thương phòng cho biệt Mỹ và làm xa tăng xa ra trình chị trọng lấp.
Cái tục khi Mỹ bày xưa ra phát đậm có tận công bởi và nè em đã mấy cảm thân thai.
Đà có nhân người bà mình sẽ nghĩ thị mạng, mời người khác bị thương nạn,
và khoảng 2 chức người bị thương nè.
Một số bị dạng dân trời chỉ chỉ chính quyền chưa có chỉ lửa sản.
Nhớ ông Trang Xuân mở bài tỏ, tâm thông trang đã tỏng xa một mớ ngộ nộ nộ trường đồng.
Trong khi một bộ phản cử chi và nhân bật cónh vừa ngộ mại tỏ của điểm phản đối.
Gây thương phản đối.
Người lại như thống viên tàn cộng hoa cái tục hộ gàn đồng vừa sử.
Cho rằng cần suy chi sẽ kép nhằm bao đậm lợi ek bé ăn nền.
Các khảo xác rất là nhiều lận gần đây cho thấy sự chi sẽ só sếp.
Rửa các đảng phái và nhóm cử chi và nắng trên lận này cảnh gây các vị định hóa chi sẽ đúng ngoại của Mỹ.